I don't need the stat sheet tonight it
doesn't even
matter explain the scenes in the locker
room I mean I've been in a ton of locker
rooms my whole life and uh that's that's
a first for me to have that kind of
um it wasn't relief it was just like
thank God you know finally and uh guys
were
screaming I was almost in tear years and
um I'm just so happy for our guys I'm
happy for everybody in the locker room
um you know sometimes it just takes a
win like that to get things started and
all the situations that um our young
guys are growing in um was pretty cool
to be in it and come out on top even
though in the midst of it you know if
you check my armpits and other places
right now wouldn't
but at the same time um the locker room
was just it it was pretty cool and um I
just have so much respect for our team
the way they come in every day I I've
said it so many times and I think
people may have thought that they were
okay with losing but they came in every
day with a great spirit and they wanted
answers and they came in wanting to
learn and try to get better we barely
came into the the gymm with um a bad
Spirit we always had our joy because we
knew that
um if we put it together we could not
just win one game but you know put many
wins together so I just respect the heck
out of our guys um really happy that we
finally got a win because it's so hard
to win in this league and
um yeah it's pretty
cool
okay the smile on your face right now
it's been a little over two months with
this describe the feelings in your heart
right now I feel
amazing oh man I feel
amazing yeah this my first time trying
not to just be you know cheesing right
now in this interview but I feel good it
was it's been a long time coming so
don't want to go back to where we
were what did you
see